one more finesse yo yo yo what's up to
Chinese man George nice to meet you
thanks for coming stuff right here by
Eminem take now heaven yeah I heard of
Eminem tag this is their you know
starting up bongs and this is their
hookahs they're all handmade in LA they
use drummer shot glass the highest grade
glass you see Gemma shot glass people
know what's up Chinese it's not American
it's German German are you German
I'm not Jeremy oh okay no from that late
these start off at like 600 bucks this
one right here goes up for 800 bucks one
of the most expensive hookers out there
but it's beautiful you know $800 $800
that's the work that's been done to it
you want to go get her like our water
Picasso you can't see anything a lot of
Picasso you know that's Picasso this is
the Picasso of poop one of the Picasso's
of Lucas I've seen a lot of expensive
bongs you know but the name of my show
is called the most expensive oh you
want the most expensive what do you
have in here why don't you just say that
when you came in you got the memo man
you artists you ready for this I'm just
like a rocket launcher this right here
on this right here is the eminent ex
Armageddon you know why they call this
farming yeah because it's the end of the
world you hit that bro what
the y'all took getting geek to
another level with this bro you know how
long it takes them to make this whole
thing takes about four days he has to
handcraft each one of these you see you
could take a hit from this Haiti you
smoking Steve told this little girl she
here let's do it I need my meds I'm
feeling down right now you mean you know
do I have a grind do you mean you you
know you walk around with a guy that I
keep going to jail grind you
have a grinder
to grind and you'll have a grinder come
yeah you got a damn bone the cost I
don't even know how much is this shitty
car this girl's for ten G's it's
beautiful it's a work of art there
chandeliers in a bunk for do you see
that and it's a German shot glass let's
not forget about that it's nine
millimeters thick
I'm a bird going stuff I pay attention
to detail I really can appreciate the
detail but ten thousand dollars for
something that takes four days to make
which only takes one minute to break
here's the thing you know this is the
only Armageddon of its kind this is
number one we got it specially made
let's see if you can handle it I'm just
trying to see let's see let's see let's
do it grind up the Girl Scout cookies
loaded up into this bazooka and then
we're gonna launch it yeah just right
here is called foresight you first
oh gee gasps Wow that's the stuff we're
doing this next me and you buddy
where's the lighter I wore mine for
socks your shoes just for this
y'all I'm not taking your head you gotta
take a hit I'm not I'm not a pro like
you trying to set me up nah all right so
what do you do now
all right so basically you just line it
up and then when the chambers get filled
up with smoke while you're pulling it
lightly you just pull the ball and then
you just suck it in all the way here
pour lightly pool and then when a guest
throw that was smoke ripping yeah we
will get gig let's go
you're not pulling I'd say you could do
it here let me show you let me show you
I'm told you know I'm slick rich brow
happy and I ain't gonna be doing all
that work my lawn check out wrapping
saying go put it is ready you ready put
it rip it off
yeah so that was my god George and he
had the most expensive bong in the world
and there was one wild and trippy
experience I can't even front I mean it
was made out of glass it had chandelier
it did everything except
glow-in-the-dark I'm not really good
with bombs and pipes and all that that
but I did enjoy the experience I'm you
know I'm a casual smoker so I didn't my
taking a trip down that road but I don't
know if I'm coming back George I'll let
you have that bro
double salute enjoy all your glass
contraptions man